so I grew up in Queens I was Prime
dominantly Italian neighborhood uh blew
a lot of blue collar workers
a neighborhood where I grew up uh your
father either owned a business or you
became a cop fireman or a gangster or
somewhere in between
my both parents are correctional
officers they worked on Rikers Island uh
Rikers Island was known as a very tough
place near Astoria Queens it was a Hazen
Street it's a lot of criminals were
there my father would come with a lot of
stories my mom worked with The
Adolescents which is one of the worst to
work with
um
I did have a sister she passed away when
I was young uh so I became the only
child
growing up I went to school I played a
lot of sports got involved in a lot of
sports uh I didn't really want to become
a cop
it's not what was on my agenda it was I
was going to play sports or do something
in medicine
so as time went on coming for Catholic
School playing sports uh growing up
around the guys I knew a lot of guys
from the neighborhood a lot of knock
around guys hung out in the street a lot
played ball tried to keep my nose clean
uh when I'm going to college with St
John's University
where I started studying Pharmacy
at that point I'd sit in class I'd stare
out and uh couldn't really just couldn't
get into it I said these people around
they didn't like me you know I had a
little something different uh I had
always had an edge to me always had to
be different do something different
and uh how about taking a police test I
remember and it was the Nassau County
Police test in Long Island some of the
highest paid
cops in the country at that time making
six figures I didn't know people said
the six figure boys I didn't know what
that was I just said okay
so I remember I forgot about it I would
uh be going to school I'd be working
some jobs bouncing uh hang out with the
guys in the neighborhood my father said
you know stay away from certain guys you
know I tried to listen
so I got a letter one day in the mail
from the Civil Service nass County
police and my father always was uh
always hard on me always meant well and
I see my my grade was like a 99.8 on
this Nassau test
I said dad 99.8 he says it's like I
think I'm I think I'm ranked like 90 out
of uh 15 000 people that took it he goes
yeah you're probably 90 from the bottom
you idiot I said 90 90 from the bottom
maybe you're right so as time goes by I
didn't have a cell phone at the time the
investigator calls the house I start the
process
I'm in school I'm still at St John's and
they told me they're going to put a
class in so it's like
walked out of school that day told my
mom and grandmother
you know typical Italian family they
started crying making the sign of the
cross uh praying you know why are you
doing this why are you doing this but uh
something I wanted to do you know went
for the Academy really liked it met a
great bunch of guys I was sold to this
dream like you know I'm gonna go out
there I'm going to make a difference
um make money uh you know you get out
there you have the uniform and Nassau
you know it's like baptism by fire they
throw your keys to a car you and you go
out on your own
and I was out there I loved it um
it's you know
it's not when you're a kid I was a young
kid coming out I was 23 years old I uh
you know worked out as a big kid so you
know you have a bit of an ego uh but you
try to learn the job you try to do your
best so I got into making uh arrests got
into making a lot of DWI arrests
which everybody was rah-rah-rah in the
beginning and then as time went by I
noticed guys started to pull away from
me
more rest I'd make they'd give you
Awards on one hand but other guys would
just pull away from you I couldn't
figure what's going on I said you know I
come home Dad I'm doing a great job here
you know I'm making arrests but a lot of
guys you know I'm getting a lot of flack
they start in these rooms they're making
stuff up
he says well you know you got to go with
the program a little you got to back off
a little I said I'm doing my job I do
yeah I'm stopping drunk drivers I'm
stopping them from killing people well
I'd get these things I get PPA cards the
people were drunk try to hand them to
you and you know I'm going to a few
accident calls when I first saw the job
and I'll never forget one who was a
young girl uh it was near one of the
holidays and she uh she was killed by a
drunk driver
so it really hit home to me in a certain
way when I thought about it and um I'm
like you know this is it's a it's a
crime that it shouldn't happen
so I I was even more aggressive locking
drunks up and the more people I locked
up especially influential people became
restaurant owners or if they're related
to a cop I got a lot of slack and a lot
of flack back
um I was making really good money at the
time working hard
and now I started uh as time went on I
said you know I'm gonna do my 20 years
and I'll be out of here but towards the
end of my career I start you know doing
a little more and it comes one night I
pulled over someone and it turns out it
was a cop's mom
she was intoxicated I
did the cost stop
uh wind up arresting her at that point
it didn't go well
uh for me after that she uh
you know the son got involved he was a
he was a cop somewhere and um you know I
can't blame the woman but
it is what it is it turned into this big
Fiasco where the whole department will
start to turn on me you know a lot of
people especially the higher-ups of the
commissioner on started to say oh it was
a false arrest it was this it was that
it wasn't a false arrest you could
nitpick anything and you know pull it
apart but it wasn't a false arrest
so at that point I was like you know
what I don't really need this I'm not
going to be harassed my name directs her
to mud
so my point is like that one little
thing they make into a huge thing it's
like they want you to make a rest but
they really don't want you to make a
rest of certain people if it's a
restaurant owner if it's uh you know
somebody influential they really don't
want it done unless it's a bad accident
so I would uh I looked at that I was
like you know what this is crazy and a
lot of people when they look at police
work a lot of people say a lot of copies
of black and white thing it's a black
and white thing people I've never won no
cop ever came across them and said I'm
going to pull over a black guy tonight
I'm going to arrest the black guy most
cops to be honest most cops look for a
thing called a no-hitter a no-hitter is
basically you have no calls that night
that's that's a great night for a cop I
was aggressive I was you know I was out
there but most cops are looking for that
the upper echelon when where Summit
corruption is they want you to look at
that black and white thing and keep
looking at it you know it's the direct
it's to distract you from really what's
going on
I mean we'd had guys on a job that were
you know did things and they stayed on
the job for for crimes and other guys
that you know did a little thing and
they were off the job so it depends on
that and I would never I'd not denounce
anything police officer because the guys
in Patrol have it so tough out there I
respect them 100 it's the guys that get
far removed from Patrol is where the
problem becomes when you're so far
removed you forgot when you were a cop
you just deal with paperwork all day you
forget that guy on Patrol Those Patrol
guys out there it's it's very hard for
them to be out there you know and um
when I left the job
jobs instilled in your head this is it
if you lose this job if you leave here
you'll never get any on the job you'll
never do anything but when I left I
there was a whole other career out there
for me of business opportunities money
to make
um it just opened my mind a lot more you
know and honestly today the way policing
is it it's hard to change if I I don't
have any children but if I had a child I
wouldn't want to be a cop today not in
the climate it is it's a very very rough
climate out there the up Echelon a lot
of times do not have you back anymore
um whether right or wrong I believe in a
lawful Society
I believe in one that you know you have
to uphold the law but um we also got to
be kept in check also our Echelon has to
be kept in check
do you regret anything you did while you
were a cop uh the only thing I regret I
probably should have made more arrests
that's what I regret that I would have
made more arrests
um
that's really it I have no other regrets
because it made me who I am being on the
job made me who I am it molded me a lot
I made a lot of good friends
on that job that you know stuck with me
through a lot of things you know I've
been through a lot in my life and I did
make a lot of good friends on that job
it's definitely what do they say um I
was watching a movie once and they said
it was the greatest show on Earth as
being a cop and that's the truth because
it I don't know if it was uh what movie
it was I can't recall
but I remember uh it's like you know
even when I was a little kid you see a
police car and you see a crowd and
everybody looked towards that cop like
he had the answer like he was the guy
and then that fascinated me always
that's the point did fascinate me about
police work it's like no matter what you
know you walk into somewhere with that
uniform you go to a call people are
looking for you and that's why it takes
a certain type of person you know you
can't be I remember I was in the academy
it's a funny quick story
um
struck this talk and he goes hey he goes
all right you're called to uh a place I
forgot where he says uh call to a place
a guy has a knife he's uh holding a
woman give his whole scenario guy in the
front raises his hand he goes what do
you do I call 9-1-1 immediately this
instructor goes crazy because you are
9-1-1 yeah [__] [__] you know so
it's things like that you know there's
stories for the job I could go and
people would not believe what what
happened
um
a real another quick story is uh
I was on patrol one night I pull into
the spot it's off off the L.A the Long
Island Expressway familiar with New York
it runs East and east and west I pulled
in I would usually eat my food
um at this spot off noi Park Road I pull
in and uh I see a car there and it was a
it was a spot where maybe a guy and girl
would go to mess around screw around so
I go and I put the lights on because I'm
not going to bother anybody I just want
them to get out of this so I could eat
and relax
the uh put the lights on car doesn't
move I never forget it was like a Saab
old school Saab put the lights on again
car doesn't move it's all right now I'll
get you out of here I pull up to the car
go around the driver's side take my
flashlight I see it it's a gentleman
alone he's got his pants down and he's
having basically has his
dick in a chicken that you buy from
Pathmark I'm going to town on a thing
I'm like yo what are you doing
he's like nothing nothing he drops it
he's like get on the car so I get him
out what are you doing he's like oh yeah
nothing nothing I said listen I'm like
you know I'm going to lock you up then
I'm like I can't lock this guy up I'll
be laughing stock in the report so I'm
like you know what what are you doing
tell me the truth he's like my wife
she's sick I don't want to go to a
prostitute this feels like a woman
so now my blind like you sick [__] I'm
like take the [__] chicken get out of
here you know so I leave I think I tell
somebody I call the guy at work when I
say come down here I tell him again
you're full of [__] you're foolish how
does this [__] happen to you it was like
the weirdest [__] would happen to me
wherever I went stuff would happen it
was the strangest [__] I had a woman one
time she's uh I get there they're
fighting on the lawn and at night in
Long Island you know it's uh it's quiet
the part of the priest I was working at
the time
and I hear you hear like uh the radio go
off you don't respond for a domestic
nobody really wants to go you get two
cars aside
so all of a sudden I pull up there's a
naked woman on the lawn I'm like be
advised to have a naked female all of a
sudden it's like everybody's responding
so I got this woman alone she's swinging
to stay at the guy swinging at her
husband we separated him it's a dildo
that's what you guys doing she's like
it's masturbation night and he was late
when he came here he said masturbation
tonight
let's roll these people out here I'm
like here for Queens what's wrong with
them
so we you know I take them we separate
and go into the house she goes well do I
look fat I'm like no you don't look fat
at all thank you she's like well said
she says the magic word she wants to
kill herself I'm like you got to be
kidding now we gotta go to Medical
Center strap her on the trundle with the
ambulance and uh I'm like what happened
here I talked to the husband very nice
guy he's like ah she's got mental
problems you know I'm supposed to come
home early it was a masturbation night
the therapist said and she got man hit
me with the dildo so I'm like this is
ridiculous
anyway if we bring her out to the
ambulance we have a new rookie working
with us he's like oh what do you want me
to do I drive the Angels no grab grab
the dildo beg it for evidence you know
joking around
so he you know I forget about we go to
the hospital to report finish up the
hospital but we'll tell you they get to
start a radio she's got to be kidding
come in here see what's up why'd this
kid bringing a dildo in here with
evidence or whatever are you a kid it's
in the locker there's something wrong
with you I said there's something wrong
with me that was a joke it's not a
[__] joke he's like you guys [__]
around too much so that part of the job
we play around I mean we just uh
just funny funny stuff we do you bring
it home to your family to your wife
um no you know at the time you know it's
hard like when I dealt with kids um a
kid that died we had I don't think it's
very hard you know a kid or immediately
for me seeing a kid or an animal die is
uh it's horrible you know it's just
horrible so what it is a lot of cops and
um
they'll say they'll make humor out of a
lot of things because not to go crazy
basically because you stop bringing that
home with you and you don't laugh about
it you know you don't you don't have any
not humorous but you gotta find the
lightest side of it otherwise if you
keep on bottling them up and bring it up
which a lot of cops do and eventually
you know lead to um alcoholism and stuff
like that
you know if that's what happens and it's
it's it's sad because a lot of guys
especially working you know I worked in
a good part of Long Island we were busy
and a lot of calls I got involved in a
lot of stuff uh but you know obviously
you're exposed to more when you work in
the city you work in in ghetto areas I
mean crime can happen anywhere but uh
you know I was very fortunate you know I
made a very good living at it of what I
did
um I was very fortunate to have what I
have
I was very fortunate to have the
experiences I had
um you know the experiences go on and on
the stories the stories go on and on
they'll last me for life it's it's funny
I go down to Mar-A-Lago I go a lot and I
deal with different business stuff I
deal with a lot of hiring hiring people
and uh you know I was just a cop that's
all I was I had no big business
background but it's funny you sit in
tables with people that you know CEOs of
companies and all this stuff and all
they want to hear they don't want to
hear from the CEO of another company hey
what have you a cop you haven't hear
this you ever do this or you know the
stories go uh endless nobody has stories
like this you can run a Fortune 500
company for 20 years you'll never get a
story like being a cop for one week and
it's just amazing the stories you have
and you tell people and people like no
that can't be you gotta be making that
up
I mean it's just endless and it's a life
experience and and you know it's
something I loved it's terrible the way
it ended for me how many years were you
I did a little over 20 years
in New York and um you know I it was it
was fun in the beginning it was a lot
different 20 years ago when I got on so
in the end you got forced out in the end
I retired on my own I decided you know
what I'm gonna I started riding on a
wall saw where it was going and I see
now they're writing on the wall where it
went and I'm glad I got out actually and
they actually in the long run they did
me a favor you know when everything
happened they say everything happens for
a reason and it absolutely because I I'd
enjoy my life when I got into better
bigger business opportunities with
people
um you know and I I always stayed I
didn't just my thing was I didn't stay
with a lot of cops I was in Aura I'll go
out and drink I I stayed with guys I
grew up with you know even today like I
stayed with guys if you know Johnny a
light very good friend of mine my doubt
a good friend of mine Larry Mazza just
guys you know with different backgrounds
but it's just you know with guys that
that family oriented guys you know when
we get along and people don't like you
know a lot of times who I stay oh you're
a copy you stay with these guys I don't
care you know know a lot of these guys
would after me in hard times in my life
and that's what I look at I don't look
at what you did I don't look at the
person people say you are I look at how
you treated me that's the main thing and
and you stay by my side so you know I
just you know
I hold my friends true and close to me
and um that's the way I live my life
it's a short life we have you know you
have to enjoy every minute of it and um
you know I'm here and if my story could
help a cop out there you know don't
think it's like you're having problem at
the end of your career I don't think
it's over uh don't look towel call don't
look to the barrel of a gun don't look
to none of that suicide's not the ants
alcohol's not the answer you can reach
out to me if you want
um I'll talk to you but uh it's not the
end it's not the end don't let these
jobs put you in a position where your
life is over and don't make the job your
life always have something else that's
the best advice I give to a young guy
getting on also you know have something
else
all right Mike thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome
fascinating
good luck with everything thank you
thank you